people ask me if I get asked to do the  voice a lot I don't I don't I don't get  asked to do uh  before you leave I'm gonna have you sing  I've Got You Babe  very rarely once a cop who pulled me  over asked me to do it did he ask you to  do it or are you just trying to get out  of a ticket hey you know I am he asked  me he asked me to do it and I I thought  this is kind of messed up a little bit  here  I did I didn't want to get out of the  ticket he he just said look I can give  you a blah blah blah and a warning but  can you do the laugh for me which I  think is probably illegal but uh so now  I'm gonna get thrown in jail because I  would participate so you're in your car  this guy's writing a ticket and you're  just looking up at him going he went  back to his car recognized the name and  asked if I was a guy and he was a nice  guy he was talking about but you're  sitting in your car yeah looking at him  and what did you do oh I went  [Laughter]